so i made the fire
what's up guys and gals
i'm gonna go climb that hill right there
even though it's not as accessible and
it's
easy to get to there's no one around
it's a great feeling i made it i lost my
selfie stick
i'm up here i can see my car it's kind
of blocked
most of it but i might climb another
mountain
no trails sun hiking without a trail
going wherever my heart pleases trying
not to step on snakes
freaking out man
i don't know why i came up here around
here
and i feel like beautiful
it's pretty scary what's up guys it's
good to be here in the
mucho borango cargo muchacho
mountains
i built a little fire here and
about the little unstable surface so i
could place my meats on here
and now they're going to heat it up
christ
so this is just the landscape that i'm
in
i'm on top of this giant [ __ ]
mountain for no reason again
and i'm on the tippy top pretty much
ah this thing moves nothing should be
moving up here everything should be
still
ah it's windy
beautiful oh beautiful
it's beautiful
[Music]
on top of a mountain for no
reason i hope i don't
[ __ ] die
all done what's up guys i'm just getting
some
walmart i'm just in my car at
like 11 15 p.m in the [ __ ]
night time i got all this [ __ ] that i
have to [ __ ] deal with
i got groceries i got a
bag of those stuff i got
laundry it's my laundry
i gotta get it all done before i go to
sleep even more
[ __ ] tiredest [ __ ]
because this is what my bed looks like
i don't cut any linens on it
so i have to do all this stuff
oh and just i just feel so exhausted i
went through a lot today emotionally
you don't even know it's so hard and my
heart is hurting i thought my
car's battery was dead because
it was and then i had to get some random
stranger to jump me
and costco away from my laptop
i'm walking out of here with my brand
new laptop
hp all black baby what's up guys i'm
here at this
uh laundromat they're closed
but uh their wi-fi is still open
so i'm using it back here
in my van
got some starcraft 2. it's some ribs
[ __ ] outside is freedom i'm here in
front of the locker room
listening to some of you you're going to
be very young
i love potion castle right now i'm on
the side of the highway because my car
just stopped running all of a sudden i
don't know what the [ __ ] is wrong with
this stupid thing man
it's i did an italian
should be more greek i don't know what
greeks sound like
i'm [ __ ] little boys and i'm doing
philosophy hey
get out of here 7 30 in the morning next
day
parked right here all night now i'm
gonna try to start the car see if it
works try to get into town
i'm stuck here carl and start
i'm at this uh mechanic shop they said
that they
might not get to it today they might not
get to tomorrow
and that i have to leave when they close
up
but they didn't say any of that over the
phone they said it when i showed up in
person
with my failing engine as i puttered
into their
goddamn shop so now i'm just squatting
here
i got all the ethanol out of my car
i hope
take the exit on the right then turn
right
you